hi you two I'm Jim Shiro the CEO of
Zurich Financial Services and as they
know I'm in Davos there's a lot of
dialogue going around regarding the
current economic crisis the
responsibility that people must take for
that crisis and yes I think as part of
the financial services community we have
to say we didn't deliver on their
promises and we failed to deliver on
those promises I had the opportunity to
participate in a panel discussing the
importance of values
I think values are important executives
should be accountable living up to those
values I'm not sure that the publication
of a series of ethics policies I think
most companies have a policy that says
these are the ethics we expect of our
executives I think the important thing
is we have to hold executives
accountable from living those policies
and I think that's really the foundation
of the values that excellent companies
do have so I'm optimistic as we go
through this process that you'll see a
greater light shine on those people who
are truly living the values of their
organizations